we have a suite from unusual whales says
this is wild yesterday a fake account
tweeted that Eli Lilly and Co was giving
insulin for free it was verified on
Twitter Lily is now down five percent or
roughly 20 billion dollars here's the
tweet it gets crazier because it's not
just Eli Lilly they tweeted out with his
fake it's Eli Lillian Co verified we are
excited to announce insulin is free now
take a look at this from Investors
Business Daily Eli Lilly Dives after
fake Twitter account promises free
insulin takes Novo Nordisk sanify with
it
Twitter's Twitter's uh awesome Twitter
is going crazy there was a bunch of uh
fake posts that were pretty uh hilarious
George Bush was I was just going to say
the George W bush one me too yeah George
W bush allegedly posted I miss killing
Iraqis and Tony Blair
me too Lockheed Martin said that they're
gonna stop selling weapons to Israel
Saudi Arabia and the United States based
on an investigation into human rights so
so there's someone trolling here and and
at the at the end of the day you know
big Pharma already made a lot of profit
this is not gonna really hurt them and
it's not going to hurt them like they
hurt the American people that's right
look I was thinking about this uh
earlier one I really liked was from
Nestle it said we steal your water and
sell it back to you
no but what I was thinking is as I was
driving back from dinner I was just like
man this is really crazy all this
stuff's happening and then I was like
this is like the coolest thing ever yeah
it's it's just everything's been so
routine and so boring and these these
fake tweets because of Elon has resulted
in like a shock to the system this is
exactly what I've been talking about
Elon Musk threw a pie I've been saying
figuratively throw that right 15. yeah
it's very it is
we're wrong it's not the Santa it's Elon
South African but he does get a lot of
money from the government but but what
he did here is is maybe Twitter
residents before haven't we sorry no oh
wait don't get don't go there but but he
did make Twitter very interesting and
this could be why there's allegedly
record users on the platform today
because it's it's so wild it's so crazy
you never know what's going to happen
you're not losing that's the thing is
that Twitter's not losing you users so
we're losing money yeah well we will see
but the
they're not
they might go to business Elon actually
said we may not survive the economic
downturn unless we get subscribers but
that was when he took it over no no this
was like a day ago no that's what I'm
saying
I'm saying into a
fish yeah look at what's happening with
Facebook
sort of there's no the ad Revenue
stopped the big advertisers pause their
money oh right activists went and said
do it or else yeah elon's like we gotta
fill that Gap with subscriptions and now
there's no they can't do that what they
might do is make it so that Twitter blue
verified accounts are the the only way
to see tweets and all non-paid accounts
will go into like a sub category that
you have to search for like you can we
were already there though I was Shadow
banned for 11 months it was crazy on
Twitter so like so so I was at 100 I
never wanted to be this guy I mean I'm
not a guy but I never wanted to be this
guy that's like whining about their
followers but I gotta say for 11 months
I was at exactly
94.3 and it was only after I had hit
100K in less than a year so when you hit
that number something got triggered so
all of a sudden Elon buys Twitter and in
a week I'm back up over 100k yeah
I'll give you a simple version as to
exactly what happened
the reason Twitter was the Free Speech
wing of the Free Speech party was big is
because it was operating on investor
cash
they built up this big platform making
something fun and exciting then the
investors came and said when do we get
our return and they said we will start
selling ads they did The Advertiser said
hey we want to buy more ads but you got
a bunch of Nazis on the platform and
they said okay we'll ban them then a
bunch of actus activists were like that
conservative guy is also a Nazi and they
said okay we'll ban them exactly they
slowly started chopping away at the
Block trying to make something they
could sell to advertisers killing the
whole system in the process in 2015
Twitter was on the verge of shutting
down completely people don't know this
it was about to go out of business until
Donald Trump signed up or he was on that
Donald Trump was already there until he
came in and started tweeting up a kafifi
and then all of a sudden it was exciting
ads were making money again but Twitter
had to keep censoring because the
activists were screaming and the
advertisers were listening this is the
best analysis I think I've heard on on
what actually happened this is this is
exactly what happened that's that's
pretty good and so by that inside the
company Jack Dorsey is like we need to
find a way to make this work and so he
promises me years ago like we're going
to create a path to Redemption they
never do and it's because of this Elon
comes in and says I'm going to bring
excitement back to the platform and the
advertisers immediately jump ship now he
says they're burning four million
dollars a day
subscription is the only way to save the
platform or he should gut the whole
thing the video files should be done
through like BitTorrent or or
decentralization
I'll tell you you look at parlor gab
Mastodon there certainly not spending
four million a day to operate Elon could
grind the whole company down to a
skeleton crew and make it a Bare Bones
text communication platform video and
photo can be hosted on other platforms
you can do a partnership with Rumble
that'll cut his costs way down
and that was
pretty on point are you on the showstop
or are you on the platform and how do
you like it uh so far uh well I tell you
what you know and when it when it first
started I was having a lot of fun
because there was just so many
ridiculous you know stupid cat memes and
and all kinds of fun stuff I mean I had
I had I was having a gas uh just clown
that's pretty much what I do now on my
on my side I try not to take it too
seriously because it's just it can get
too heavy life is so heavy as it is with
everything that's going on it's not for
serious you know so I so that's what I
attempt to do even if I'm making
political comments I try to do it in an
offhanded sort of way that hopefully
brings some some kind of sense of humor
to it rather than just like always just
being dark about everything you know I
hear you yeah the person I am on Twitter
I I believe or I hope is not the person
I am in real life like I've tried to
explain to people like how to have a
good Twitter account or whatever not
like I have some great Twitter account
but it's like I I my way of saying it is
um the worst parts of my personality oh
I saved for Twitter I'm like I'm
actually a nice person so people meet me
in real life and they're like oh like
you're actually like really nice and
like not like like because on Twitter
all I do is shred people but I shred
people on my side that's the thing if
we're gonna play sides here politically
I shred people on the political right
who are lying to people I shred phonies
that's my big thing right like
there's a lot of ponies out there yeah
and so like that's that's where I kind
of find my role because I don't work for
anybody and so everybody works for
somebody right like everybody thinks
they're gonna come back into some
magical Administration or something like
that I am the boss like what am I gonna
fire myself so that's the one thing I
can give is to be truthful what what I
do on Twitter is I basically just uh
tweet the exact opposite of things
yeah that not for great no that's
awesome 4D Trump chess today oh no I
said 12th dimensional I know and then I
said Trump Trump's level of Chess
playing is so Advanced he surpassed M
Theory it's very esoteric M3 has 11
Dimensions Trump's playing 12
dimensional chess but uh no I I can't
say exactly what I tweet not on YouTube
but that's the point is I realize that
if you tweet something that's factual
based on factual news and a link to the
news story the media will twist the
context of what you said to make you
look bad and they'll accuse you of
things you didn't actually do so this uh
election Integrity project or whatever
accused me of being one of the biggest
spreaders of like election
misinformation or something which is
totally false because I use newsguard
which is this like you know they did a
partnership with Microsoft for funding
and they fact check and so all the
stories I'm putting out are just basic
you know so then I realized okay all I
got to do is share the story and say the
opposite and then I win because now they
can't accuse me so I'll like if I see a
story that is shocking to the narrative
that you know Biden commits ex-crime
I'll say this is clearly false Biden
would never do something like this you
are all crazy conspiracy theorists
that's how I operate on Twitter and uh
but some of the tweets are real so you
just you never know that's awesome and
that why that way if you're a journalist
you have to ask me for a comment to
figure out which one's actually how I
feel or not there you go I'm just there
for the meme that's not bad the memes
are are I think a Lifeline to free
civilization that could actually save us
during these very difficult times but
but always oh the Hat the hammer thing
has brought up some just memes that have
just been oh oh no they've been just so
funny what I had to do the hammer
wrestling match oh yes the the the pink
hammers
you insert batteries into yeah
um but that's again family friendly show
here I apologize here but it's not just
Twitter having difficulties here the
corporate media is now reporting that
Twitter was only able to get about a
half a million dollars from Twitter blue
itself that's some of the reports that I
haven't have a million only half a
million dollars was able to be made off
of Twitter blue According to some
corporate media it was like a day I mean
how long has it been allowed I mean it's
been out for today in total that's
that's
what
yeah one week that's half a million for
the whole month no no and they paused it
they paused it until Wednesday so it's
like literally been two days yeah well
you're saying still you're saying they
paid eight dollars everyone's paying for
a 30-day thing they've made half a
million dollars in 30 days subscriptions
and but they need four million a day
yeah so they need 30 what's up slow down
it's been like two days they pause it
until Wednesday they kicked it open if
they made half a million dollars within
so it was like uh I think it was I I
think it was Tuesday I was able to no no
it wasn't it was Wednesday they pause it
for the midterms and then Wednesday it
went live and then it was shut down
early late last night or early in the
morning so it was barely last night
barely up for two days and he made half
a million in subscriptions they're gonna
get that same half a million again next
month but fair point they need 4 million
per day thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
show shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time